[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX WELCING: We're looking at
using Google Cloud's Natural
Language processing
for understanding
health taxonomy in
work you do internally,
government published
regulatory analysis
and research done by life
sciences groups, insurances.
The concept being, we
wanted to very quickly
be able to read large
amounts of documents
saved in traditional file
formats like PDFs, text,
HTML pages.
If you think of the
organizational knowledge
sprawl, you would see at
an enterprise health care
organization, you
have critical work
that's been done and only
lives in one workstation.
So the context for
this presentation.
My name's Alex Welcing.
I am a consultant
at Manatt Health.
It's a group within Manatt,
Phelps, and Phillips.
It's a legal regulatory
policy group.
Our clientele covers
everything from life sciences,
state federal governments,
insurance places.
And we've got extraordinary
depth of expertise
in areas like Medicaid.
I don't have any of that.
I came over a year ago from
a pulsing tech startup,
where we were making interactive
games inside of articles.
We were being able to scrape
the content on the page
and make it interactive.
I wanted to bring cutting
edge development using things
like the NLP API to solve
this very, very simple,
but understanding how
complex the problem can
get of connecting our
documents together.
So we'll walk through
what we've done there,
but if you want to be
able to do something
like this for yourself
at your organization,
we took a prototyping
and tooling approach
to this project.
What we built isn't live yet.
It's not something
that's a model that we've
deployed and count
as a production
implementation of
natural language
understanding in health care.
We didn't do that.
Instead, we've built
something that we
can start up and
destroy in 30 minutes
and extract the business
value we need from it.
When you think about the
organizational resources
you need to bring something
like this to market,
we were able to save
a lot of effort there.
And avoid a lot of
regulatory concern
around what we're doing
with this information
because it's a very
temporary analysis.
So if you want to be
able to follow along,
create a new project in
Google Cloud Platform.
Also, you had to startup the
Google Cloud Engine and load
in a web app where you're going
to display your final results.
As well as do the actual calls.
So a little further
context around our product.
Our client base wanted access
to our knowledge collective.
We've done work for
public-facing foundations
like RWJ, Commonwealth, CHIP.
At the same time, we've
done a lot of internal work
just to keep our expertise
up-to-date, where
we do 50 state trackers
looking at telehealth policies
across the country.
We put all of this available
to our clients starting
January 1, 2018.
We had about a four or
five month ramp time
since I joined to
official launch.
So if you think of the
timing of this development,
we started NLP exploration
in October 2017.
We're still working
on it today, but we're
really excited about where
we can move it forward.
The initial concept we wanted
to do, though, was very simply,
this is a piece of
content we've written.
This is an analysis of
a regulatory summary
the government just
released that's 2,000 pages.
We are going to do the
hard work of having
our lawyers read through,
diligently analyze that work.
It's my job on the web front to
connect all of that information
they wrote and looked
at effectively to all
of our other sources
of information.
And what I'm not going
to do is ask a partner
at the firm to look at
a 300-word keyword list.
And here are the
other 25 examples
of ones that have
used these keywords.
Does this make sense?
We realized very quickly,
that wasn't going
to be the successful approach.
So I wanted to be able to
empower them to understand how
our keyword strategy
was working,
but also for them, as
subject matter experts,
to guide where we were
going with our strategy,
in that regard.
So we wanted to be able to
share our tool with partners
and authors.
And finally, I want to
reach extraordinary depths
of accuracy and understanding
of our source material.
It would be very easy for
us to categorize our work
into 10 general buckets.
This is Medicaid.
This is life sciences work.
But if we could
understand hundreds
of entities in our documents
and have a salient connected
to each of those,
the more content
we build the less likely
to get lost along the way
and to lose investment we've
already made in previous work.
It helps tell a better story
if we've got a really good data
approach in that last box.
So here's the breakdown
for the tech demo.
We use the command
line interface
to extract out text from PDFs.
This is pdftotext.py.
It's a pretty simple script.
We then transfer
the text documents
to Google Cloud Storage, where
you very efficiently can do
calls to the
Natural Language API
and it's all in-house
we want to be
able to keep this very much in
the Google Cloud Platform then
we call the and now
Once we have that output,
it's going to give us a JSON.
It's going to save that
JSON into the Google Cloud
and Google Compute Engine.
And we're focusing specifically
on Analyze Entities.
I'll show you Analyze Sentiment
and Analyze Categories, as
well.
But we really got the most value
out of using Analyze Entities
option within natural language.
So we would then want to be
able to deploy for end users
to be able to view the
results of what we did.
We would want to be able to
share in a green check mark
HTTPS location, what it is
we were just looking at.
So I'll show you two
examples, in that regard.
One is a further built
out CMS integration
with our natural
language processing,
which is a user interface
using Ghost and Firebase, where
users are able to log in and do
this whole process themselves.
And then, I'll also show
you how to launch it
in a simpler version
on Hexo, which
I don't know if there's
any developers who
run their blog on GitHub,
but GitHub pages and Hexo
integration is a very
common way of hosting--
just posting your information.
So that's we're aiming for,
just posting the information.
And we do look at a wide
range of document sizes,
and I'll give you a little
bit of context around where
there's some challenges there.
I want to give this boilerplate
a really good highlight
because it's an amazing
organization that I've
looped into coming from a
very tech startup background-y
context.
I would say looking
around this conference,
there aren't many
organizations that
have the depth of legal
expertise in the health care
space.
And what I would
most love to get out
of this year's attendance
is for 10 of my colleagues
to want to come.
Our experts in data analytics
who help provider systems take
looks at their entire
collection of data.
And we've got sharing
projects in LA County.
I would love for
this tech community
to help bridge the gap with
subject matter experts further.
And for those of you who are
maybe extremely on the tech
side and are
looking for partners
on the legal and
regulatory consulting side,
that's where I would really
say, I'm not your guy.
I would love to introduce
you to my colleagues.
So very quickly, I'd like to
share a bit about our approach
towards investing into an NLP
AI because this is a lean team.
Insights at Manatt Health--
the publication that I'm a part
of--
consists of a
senior director who
oversees the editorial vision.
We have two senior
managers who help
with the production of
the content, the working
relationships with the clients.
And I manage the front-end.
I manage all of the
publication of the information.
The things that go on the site.
And our budget's rather limited.
So I still had very
real objectives
I wanted to accomplish
at our organization.
At the same time, I know
where we're trying to get to.
I know what our clients
would like from us.
And I know what our
organization would
like to bring to the table
in sharing information.
When you're at a
conference like this,
there's an opinionated stance
on open and democratized web,
that needs to be shared
and advocated for.
These two examples I've
thrown up on the screen
are two disparate
cases cited from EFF.
The first being the
Freedom of Information Act
fine of the year.
Someone wanted to
know information
about sexual assault
in Texas prisons.
It's the type of information
that's a critical health
question for our country.
And there were advocates
and data scientists
out there who spend hours
of their free time writing
into government organizations
asking for information.
It was going to cost
a million dollars just
for the labor of
scanning in the documents
to be able to
complete this FOIA.
That is a very real example
of the cost for access
to this information
and the opportunity
we have bringing NLP
into marketplace.
I didn't get anything that
was that sophisticated,
but I knew we wanted to
play in this space already.
We were ready and the
technology is already available
that myself, as not
an expert developer,
can put us on the right
path for considerations
of how to intelligently bring
this technology to market.
The second example
is another extreme
where you have to consider the
full severity of the work you
can do.
As developers and
data scientists,
the models you make--
if you want to bring
something to production,
it can't be racist.
This letter is 42
organizations that
penned to Axon, which is a
provider of law enforcement
equipment.
They were looking at
bringing to market
or beginning research after
putting together an AI ethics
board, into facial
recognition technologies.
The people who would be most
affected by these technologies
you work on have to be a part of
the process from the very start
of the development,
consideration of the idea,
through the working
models, final sign-off.
This-- I believe--
is one of the only ways we're
going to successfully get,
as a collective,
to a place where
we feel very confident and safe
with the models we're building.
More practically, think about
what your day-to-day work
life is like.
When you're thinking of
the two options of where
you can go with data science
and building models for AI,
I'd encourage you to
check out, obviously,
the other sessions that
are deep in this space,
but you see the work
that you can be doing.
The experimentation,
the testing,
the iterations on this model.
We want to be in
this middle bucket.
We want to be working
as a group all together.
Experimenting.
Writing scientific papers.
Analyzing it and feeling
comfortable with the security
we've brought.
Of course, there is still
closed source development.
I'm not saying that
your organization's not
going to have a
proprietary take on a model
that Google has made.
But I think it's
increasingly unlikely
that your internal
organization is
going to be trying to build
the Natural Language API.
You want to build the
application that uses it.
You want to be able to train
your own models for something
like that.
But we're not going to want
to be in this left bucket,
where you, as a developer or
a data scientist, your team--
no matter how well-constructed,
well-developed--
you don't want to be
standing out isolated.
You don't want to be bringing
to market production models that
haven't been proved by
the community at large.
We want a stringent
testing system.
And these questions
weighed really heavy on us
when we are looking
at NLP, even for just
analyzing our own writing
and regulatory work.
So here's the question.
You've got these two options.
I would love out of this group--
because I've seen the job
titles and organizations
who are represented here--
if I could get a
quick, close your eyes
and raise your hands for
either the first or second.
I would be fascinated to
know for my own knowledge.
So quick eyes closed,
raise your hand
if our first option
is, we're not
going to be able to
get there right now.
You're not going to be
able to hit production
because the regulation, the
technical obstacles-- it's not
clear enough.
We are not in a safe space
to be able to launch.
Or we're in the bottom
question where right now, you
could go home after
this conference
and start a project on Monday,
work with stakeholders,
diligently build a new
tool that you could bring
to market in your company
by the end of the year that
would safely have in
consideration the second.
And I apologize, there was one
person who closed their eyes
and raised their hand.
Now we can ask the question.
Close your eyes.
Raise your hand for one.
And second.
Wonderful, that's
really exciting to see.
It's exciting to see that
probably, 70% of the room
was enthusiastic about
our second option.
Truth is, I feel
like whichever you
pick is going to be
the route you go.
This slide on the right--
some you might recognize it--
this is produced
from our US Senate.
It's an analysis of
the solutions we could
take to prevent a Y2K crisis.
What I love about this is on
the left hand on your y-axis,
that's month to implement.
[? Day-to-day ?] expansions
is going to take us 48 months
to get there, but it gives the
highest performance reliability
standards against a Y2K bug.
TensorFlow came out last year.
You think of the context around
the development of our space.
And it's not just
software development.
It's the architecture.
It's the hardware that you run
your models and the networkings
that you're running it on.
This seems irrelevant,
but we will equally
have similar lack of
understanding when we look back
on our current
analysis of AI today,
where we really missed
the mark on some things,
but I do like just
rely on the experts.
I'm not going to be making
any of this up myself.
I'm not a leader
in machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
I'm a user.
I'm someone who practically
has day-to-day tasks I want
to get done and I am
grateful to be in a space
where leaders like
Fei-Fei Li are carving out
this space for us, for us
to be able to do our work.
So from 2017,
during her session,
these were four
principal components
for democratizing AI
that are essential for--
if we go back to
stakeholder involvement,
you look at the Axon example
and this is a perfect chance
to consider whether or
not we're really looking
at a democratized AI scenario.
Making sure everybody
who would be impacted
by an artificial
intelligence solution
has access to computing
resources to test it.
Has access to
training and resources
so that they themselves
can become the talent that
works on these projects.
Making sure the
algorithms and the data
that you're using and
bringing to market
is accessible to a scientific
and open community,
is going to make this
slide a lot more fun.
I've been playing in
the bottom left hand
corner, where our budgets will
range from tens of dollars.
I look at if I can
spend less than $100
and deliver you some
sort of business value,
I only have to save someone 10
minutes to make back that $100.
So I look at big opportunities
to carve out time savings.
And that's prototyping tools.
It's not going to be something
that can live forever.
It's going to have
instabilities.
There are clear spots where
that wasn't built out because it
wasn't supposed to be.
We don't want to
spend our developers
time working on something that's
not going to come to market.
And practically, my
organization doesn't
have a need for an enterprise
natural language processing
tool.
We got a question we want to
answer and AI helped us do it.
This top right corner,
though, I think we're all
passionate about getting there.
The potential impact of
bringing to market an IoT health
care device that is able
to consistently monitor
your glucose levels and it works
even when the power goes off
and the internet's gone.
And it's able to help
predict critical failures
of your health.
We all know we want to
be making new markets
and changing people's lives with
AI, but the risks around that
are scary.
I would say, for developers,
we've got some concerns.
But primarily, for investors.
There's maybe,
$10 billion a year
in the US pouring
into AI research.
And I think you
could short that.
I think you could safely say,
10X-ing that AI research would
still be a fair safe investment.
You clearly haven't
seen it, though,
and until some of those
regulatory legal concerns
get worked through and resolved
and they're a safe space
to play and bring
to market, then
maybe we continue working
on prototyping tools
and then bring them
to internal tools.
And continue to
develop a culture that
knows how to use
AI applications,
wants to build these things,
and has tested it rigorously.
You don't want in
your first one to be
the one that goes to market.
So there's a lot on this
lot and I apologize.
Let's start with the most
interesting information.
This is a paper--
I believe this is
a Google team--
that they presented
initially in February
and it won a bunch
of awards in June.
Obfuscated gradients
give a false sense
of security
circumventing defenses
to adversarial examples.
That's frightening-- I feel.
At the conference, they
won best presentation.
There were eight proclaimed
secure white box algorithms
and this took them all down.
This came out in March.
TensorFlow 1.0, which
most data scientists--
not that there's not
other models like that.
It's not like you
can't use Keras.
It's not like there's
H20.AI, but TensorFlow's
a really good example.
You look at the forks,
there's clearly interest.
That's not enough time in
between these two events
happening for me to
feel confident yet.
The other side of
this is the context,
is the thing that's weighing
us down in this consideration.
We've got Tim
Berners-Lee in 1989.
I don't think it makes sense
to start a conversation
about open web before that.
And then we have the cost
estimates for that Y2K bug.
It looks like Aetna
might be at $195 million
if Y2K doesn't go well.
And those figures seem extreme
and they seem goofy now,
but they didn't at the time.
I feel like we are going
to have similarly goofy--
not goofy, but misunderstandings
about where we are in the cycle
as we see in 1999.
And this last component
just elaborates on the idea
of investing in tools.
The left framework, I would
highly encourage you--
honestly, if
there's anything you
took away out of this
development talk,
it would be that framework.
It wasn't even originally
intended for developers.
It's the framework for strategic
sustainable development.
Came out of a group in
Sweden in the early '90s.
It's about sustainability
in the world
and it really drills it
down into a systems level.
If we talk about the system of
AI development and health care,
that would include
all of the algorithms.
The talent pool.
The hardware that's available
for you to run it in.
The end devices.
The systems that
subscribe to it.
The entire ecosystem of
everything that you touch.
It's very hard to change that.
And it's a collective effort
to make changes to the system.
But making tools
is easier and tools
are what we use to take
action in our day-to-day jobs.
If we've got better tools
to do the work that we want
to accomplish, there's
tangible benefits
in our ability to execute
the organization's strategy.
Do your job better, do your
job easier thanks to the tools.
Now you can execute
your strategy.
And if we align our strategy
with some smart goals,
that feeds all the way
up to a great system.
But the main thing
that I can say
that we're focusing
on right now is
making sure we've got talent
who we feel comfortable working
with and we've got a similar
dialogue around these tools.
We want to test a lot of
platforms and services.
I'm here at Google's
presentation,
but I would love to
run similar experiments
across the enterprise
solutions here.
There is a certain
amount of you don't
want to factor your
efforts too much
and I've been very happy in
the ecosystem I operate in.
I do all of our work in
Google Cloud Platform.
But
We want to evaluate
the platforms.
And your products should
still deliver business value
if your manager comes
up and asks hey,
I see these API calls.
What is this?
There should be something that
you're trying to get out of it.
One of the additional
components of framework
for strategic sustainable
development is backcasting.
Understanding where
you want to arrive
and where you are today and
understanding what steps
you would be taking to get
to that eventual end goal.
As opposed to forecasting,
saying historically,
here's what we've done.
Based off of those projections,
we project we will get here.
This is the opposite.
We know if we want
to get to market,
we are going to need a great
development team that's fully
bought in and is well-staffed.
We need stakeholder
buy-in from the community.
You need the patients
who are going
to be affected by your product
to know about it from the
get go.
From the first time
you had the idea
to use AI to better analyze
rhythmic patterns of the heart.
You should probably talk
to some heart patients
and find out about
their experiences.
Having regulations
in place would help.
Having very clear
guidance in that space
and that's going
to be a combination
from the government
getting involved,
as well as from the tech side
being leaders and advocates.
Cloud-first
architecture for data--
I think that makes sense.
We're at Google NEXT.
And the ability to run on-device
and in cloud computation
for the results, I
do think mentioning
on-device calculations
is important.
One of the really interesting
examples is TensorFlow.js,
but I think fundamentally
being able to do
localized calculations
is extremely helpful.
So I want to pivot now.
This is the switch
over to practical--
here's what the work looks like.
So how to analyze
hundreds of pages.
I'll give you a couple of slides
on the development process
and then, we'll switch
over to the live demo.
This is just a
consideration pyramid
for when you are taking
on a project like this.
Who are you going to
be presenting this to?
If you are sharing
the work you're
doing with this with
a development team
lead-- for example.
Someone who's very interested
in the hows and whys this
works, but wouldn't be
concerned about the appearances.
Maybe you don't need to
worry about throwing up
during the prototype
development--
a firewall that
secures all of this
within your own
internal network.
Or you don't need HTTPS
access and it's just
going to show up as a
nice beautiful IP address
that they know you could deploy
to a front end if you wanted.
On the other hand, if you're
going to be taking this work
and you're going to spend
four or five hours building
something that you feel really
comfortable and confident in
and you're going
to be sharing it
with senior executives in the
finance side who really don't
have an interest in the hows
and the whys of launching
a server in Compute Engine
and why that might not be--
it's not an unnecessary
expense or time sync,
but it looks pretty.
Having the green check mark
in a nice formatted URL
does help get the
point across clearer.
And if that's all
the amount of lift
you need to do to go from
they don't understand it
at all to the idea clicks, I
see where this would help us
and we want love
to do more of this.
Or even better, they
see it and they've
got their own ideas of I
would love something like this
to solve this problem.
Then that's a
fruitful conversation
and then it's worth going
ahead and adding in,
you can just throw
[INAUDIBLE] bot.
You can get a domain name
for less than $0.50 from
cheapnames.com.
And between those two, you've
got really no excuse for it not
to show up as an HTTPS product.
Next is the actual Compute
Engine that we used.
Simple enough, we
did a 16.04 instance.
Threw 50 gigs of
standard memory on it.
Important details
that we've got--
I went ahead and allowed full
access to the Cloud APIs.
You're still going to need to
enable the Natural Language
API once you get
into the platform
and you've got your project.
But you also make sure
you allow traffic.
And below this setting,
set a static IP address
for this engine for external
use because that way
you can connect in.
Hexo and Ghost were the two
CMS' we used when looking
at displaying our information.
Ghost is a startup that
has really, they've
committed themselves to
being a nonprofit entity
and they've been working on
a really great publishing
platform that I've been
satisfied to use or bring it
to market for an internal blog.
So you've got the
directions for Ghost.
I would highlight that you need
to use like a node v6 or v8.
It doesn't support v10 or v9.
That's the one we
added in Firebase.
I've shared the code for
that, but I haven't cleaned it
up for you in a really,
really presentable way
because your development
team knows how to do this.
You could give them
these instructions
and say, bring them your idea.
Here's the document
we would like
to categorize and organize.
They would know how to be
able to do the Firebase,
but I have shared
the example, as well.
And on the Hexo side, this
is just dead simple to use.
You're able to generate all of
your static files in a second,
for 50 or so.
So Hexo's a really easy example
to be able to get something up
and moving.
And what's
interesting is you can
do all of your user
interface things,
like I could source to
this team right here.
If each of you would
like a document analyzed,
just put it into Ghost.
Tag it with what you
think what it should be.
And then I could export all of
that and import it into Hexo.
So they complement each
other really well as far
as two CMS's just to be
able to share the info.
So here are very helpful
instructions on--
the top one is how to
deploy Ghost on GCP.
Middle one is link to
where the Firebase theme.
One other example I'll
throw out there on this
is when we did the
Ghost integration
to be able to make this call,
we didn't do any editing
on the back end.
This is on a theme level
editing only improvement.
So I kind of threw a curve ball
at the development team and I'd
like to give a shout out to
[? Braydon Kelly-- ?] he's
a father now--
and helped us bring to
market the Firebase example.
Really took the
idea and ran with it
and worked around challenges
that your team wouldn't need.
You wouldn't need to
introduce these challenges
to your product, but
we had them in ours.
And finally, the
bottom one is where
all the Analyze entities,
the Natural Language API
is located.
So let's go ahead and hop
over to the tech demo.
And oh, wow.
I apologize, the first screen
you see isn't a Google product.
That is a deployment engine.
I know the last slide
we left on said,
let's talk about how
to prep the documents,
but I'd like to
first, share with you
this is the front
end example of Ghost.
So I would like to find
a document to analyze.
I'm going to quickly log into--
Let's say we want to analyze
this text document we
did on House plans to
consider White House
rescissions package, CMS
says no lifetime limits
for Medicaid coverage.
I'm going to come
over to here and this
is all just text input, but
for the command line interface.
Here we've added
in content types.
All of this information
is stored in Firestore
so if I wanted to then go
and edit the content type
or add in new key
topics, it's as
simple as going to
my Firebase site
and adding that
into the catalog.
So here I'm indicating
what I initially think
this document would be about.
I think it's insurance and
marketplaces, fraud and abuse.
I provide a little bit of
additional info in the top line
just for visibility
on the front end.
And finally, let's take--
this is a six-page document
so it's not too bad.
We've pasted all the information
and there's nothing going on.
So we get our spinning
wheel and I've timed it.
It can be everywhere from
under a minute for something
small to taking several minutes
for larger scale content.
What I think is actually super
helpful-- oh, did it pass?
Great.
So let's see what we got.
This spits out-- so
here's what we submitted.
And then down here, we
have what we wanted.
So if I was empowering a
partner or a consultant
at our organization, I could
first, give them this resource.
Here's the URL to go to.
If they take the first step of
putting in their information
here, then from my end, I
can take what they've shared
and bring it to
market on the product.
Or I can start a
meaningful conversation
with this subject expert
who put the work together
and I can ask him, which
of these on the front page
would make sense to
tag your content for?
And we can scroll through.
Just for a little bit of
clarity, the two items
we're seeing on the
screen, you have
salience which is
really, actually,
that's what I
found most helpful.
Salience is the
importance of that word
within the entire document.
You're able to add
up count, as well.
And I will say the count gets
filtered out very nicely, also.
Some additional
info that I think
has been actually very
helpful and illuminating.
This is the Sentiment Analysis
and we printed out basically,
a by line example.
I feel like someone who's
good at text manipulation
would clean up some of
this before it goes in.
I wouldn't keep in see
page 5 for coverage.
But let me find an
interesting sentence here.
I've genuinely found
unique insights
about the regulatory
analysis that's
gotten published or
about research based
on this feature specifically.
So I've zoomed in here, let's
look at this very positive one.
Other measures include research
on new non-addictive pain
medications, loan repayment
for [? subproviders, ?]
and the creation of
comprehensive opioid recovery
centers intended to serve
as treatment models.
That's a pretty
positive sentence.
There's a lot of
loaded information
that you understand
why it would flag.
That's fine for our
specific coverage.
This is something we wrote.
I think where it's
even more interesting
is when you see something
like this 0.9 positive green
in a published piece of
government regulation
or an announcement of
upcoming regulation.
Because regulation's not
particularly emotional.
It's not supposed to have
these flowery languages.
And if I have time, I can
share a specific example of one
we found.
Uniquely passionate
advocacy within one line.
And looking at the time,
I'm going to now pivot over
to showing you how to do--
Lastly, they've got
categories, as well.
I'm just showing
this to you to show
it hasn't gotten there yet.
The categories API
is fantastic if you
have broad ranges of content.
If you're specifically
within one section,
like law and government
or health care,
it might not be as
informative for you
because I kind of
knew our content was
health care and law-related.
That didn't help
narrow it down for me.
So who wants to see it in
the [? Console ?] side?
Let's find a good
little workspace.
So really quickly,
let me show you--
these are examples of
the different web apps
we've used to deploy the info.
I think all of these
are accessible in one
state or another.
Making a brand new
Hexo post or site
is as easy as pseudohexoinit.
Let's call this GCP live.
And it's going to go and
pull in all of the info
I need to have a
working web app.
While that runs, now
I almost regret even
giving it the option to do so.
Let's go and look at some
of the text documents.
In my Google Cloud Storage,
I'll show you the final result
of what we've done.
So you have first,
final JSON outputs.
If you look at the
file sizes, it's
substantial in the sense of that
for a JSON, things reaching 1/2
a meg, 1 meg, plus is
a lot of information.
So realize that each
of these is going
to seem unnecessarily large.
This is what it looks
like at the outset.
You really do need to
filter down into it
to extract the information.
Let me take my Q2--
here is the text output.
I would like to show you
pdftotext all the way through.
And I feel like I can get there.
So let's knock this out.
I've got Q2 content
in a zip in the Cloud.
So let's--
Did we get it?
Yeah, we did.
Instead of me
trying to live code
that specific function of
it, what I'm going to do is
show you the cool
fancy final product
of what our analysis was.
I've got the
instructions in later
slides that we
didn't get to on how
to actually do the pdftotext.
It's super simple.
But I am really
interested in sharing what
this final output looked like.
This is 25% of our most
recent publications
that we took a look at.
And the final output
of that JSON I
just exported out to Tableau.
And what you're seeing
on the left on the y-axis
is salience per entity.
And on the left on the
x-axis are keywords.
I'm having to zoom in a lot
to even get to a point where
the keywords aren't
so spread out
because across 25 documents,
we would have tens of thousands
of entities generated
and it listed those
all the way across,
but let's keep
zooming in to see what
some of these look like.
And all of a sudden, I'm able to
start getting some real insight
into connections
between documents
from a source like this.
So for example, CMS
was 0.0141 importance
to this analysis on
the new payment model.
Versus something like this
that came in at 0.1385.
And I know all of
these documents
have info related to CMS
that reached a critical mass
to categorize it in here.
White House came up
in this group of five.
We can view each individually.
With that being said, here are
the last slides in 30 seconds.
Here's that.
Here's an initial result.
Here is the video of me
walking it through on Ghost.
And here is the
final wrap-up slide
of what we came into it
with and what we left with.
It's been a really
exciting project.
And if I've got 15
seconds left, I just
have to thank
countlessly, the team that
helps support this work--
the senior leadership, as
well as [? Lauren Thomas, ?]
my fiance, for helping
me walk through the deck
and get here today.
Thank you so much for
your time, as well.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]